foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
deep space spatio-temporal insights into
Copa 19 a multi-organ study this webinar
is part of the lab Roots coronavirus
virtual event series I will be the
moderator for today's webinar my name is
Elizabeth Schneider senior Global
Marketing Manager here at Nano string of
course today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab Roots sponsored by
those of us at nanastring for more
information about Nana string and our
products and Technologies please go to
our website
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive and we encourage
you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
the new live chat feature during the
presentation you can find the live chat
located at the right of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you would like during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click submit we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation
and don't fret if we don't get to your
question we will be collecting all the
questions and follow up individually
with those of you whose questions
weren't answered during the live q a
um and uh if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
help desk button located at the bottom
of your screen within the navigation bar
or from the lobby of the event
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speaker
Dr arusa kulasinga he's an nhmrc
research fellow at the University of
Queensland
and he leaves the clinical omics Lab at
the University of Queensland and Dr
kulasigna has pioneered spatial
transcriptomics using digital spatial
profiling approaches in the asia-pacific
region contributing to world's first
studies on lung cancer had a neck cancer
in Coven 19. and his research aims to
understand the underlying path of
biology by using an integrative
multiomics approach he's published his
research in 50 manuscripts likely more
than 50 by now and he supported in
addition to the nhmrc by AAS cure cancer
mrff and numerous philanthropic and
Hospital foundations thank you so much
arutha for joining us for this
interesting talk and thanks everyone for
being on the line to listen to your
presentation today
thank you for the wonderful introduction
Elizabeth I'm really looking forward to
this and thank you lab roots for the um
invitation to talk about some of our
really exciting work in in covid-19
um this all stemmed a couple years ago
where we you know through an extensive
collaboration we've been able to access
really rare samples and we've done a
deep dive using spatial biology so I'm
based in Brisbane Australia that's a map
of Australia you can see there and I'll
tell you a bit about our sort of
exciting work we've been doing over the
last couple of years and and what it's
led to
um the talk title deep spatial temporal
insights into covid-19 are multi-organ
study and I've acknowledged a number of
funding agencies so what you see here is
the map of Australia and on the right
um is it looks like a bronoi plot which
we use for spatial sort of interactions
but it's actually the indigenous
communities within Australia so you know
it all goes back and it's all connected
so it's a really nice depiction of
you know how this is um you know this
sort of segues into this work
so this work really
um
began from this study that was published
in the New England uh in in April 2020
which looked at Bob genomic assessments
um of covid-19 South cup 2 infected
lungs and compared it to
um H1N1 pandemic H1N1 and one of the
takeaway messages from this was that
there was this um this this Venn diagram
which showed differentially expressed
genes but also genes that were shared
between covid-19 and and H1N1 and it
really piqued our interest as to whether
we could apply the methods that we
developed in the lab using spatial
approaches to really try to delineate
what was going on in the um in the
tissues of of covid-19 uh uh studies so
um one of the approaches we've used and
one of the Technologies we've used is is
this digital spatial profiling from Nano
string Technologies which essentially
allows you to take a single unstained
ffpe tissue section so that's the
biggest benefit of this technology that
you can you can use samples that are
archival that are in pathology banks
that are shipped at room temperature
around the world and we've been able we
were we were lucky enough to access some
of this material and and you can
essentially take an unstained tissue
section you can Define your regions of
interest within that and you can
Liberate the um
that the transcript of the protein data
off that tissue using these tiny mirrors
which shine UV light above the regions
of interest and it liberates these oligo
tags uh for the cleavable linkers which
are then deposited in a 96 volt plate
and you get uh counts per region of
Interest so digital expression data per
region of interest within that tissue
and the beauty of this technology is
really in that you know you can do it
off a single unstained tissue section
and and some recent data that was shown
at ACR was that you could do protein and
RNA off a single section which is uh
really exciting because as what we've
traditionally done is we go through
serial sections to do protein but now
that you're able to do it off the same
tissue sections really really powerful
um so I'll talk about some of the the
work that that led to this so we had
through extensive collaboration through
puritiba in Brazil we had access to
covid-19 uh lung autopsy samples these
are prepared into a tissue microwave
block 10 examples in in 10 patient
samples in the covid-19 block 10 H1N1
this is the 2009 pandemic and Tomo
non-uh non-viral debt uh control samples
so we essentially h e stand these Rand
Mason's Tricom for fibrosis IHC for the
spike protein RNA scope for the virus
tempers 2 ace2 and at the time sort of
August 2020
um where we didn't really have any cases
in Australia
um which was we were lucky as a country
we had Pathologists that were invested
in the literature and and they
collaborated with us to actually
characterize these tissues even though
they'd never seen covid-19 autopsy
samples at that time
um so Caroline Cooper was was
collaborated with us from create
hospital and we ran the nanospring
geomix DSP covid-19 immune Atlas panel
which was what was the panel that was
available at that time in in in in
August 2020 which is a
a panel developed over the cancer
transcript or mattress panel with about
50 spiking covert spike in our genes and
since then we've run the whole
transcriptome which is 18 000 Flex which
allows you to do a deep dive on the cell
typing and and and so on and the
bioinformatics was was handled through
the uh water analyze the whole Institute
uh specifically from Melissa Davies lab
chimwee Tang a number of collaborators
from there and this is just going
through those uh tissue samples showing
the virus and the red by RNA scope and
what we did following the discovery
approach with the tissue is we went on
to test um and I'll talk briefly about
this uh test some of the gene signatures
or some of the genes that were
differentially expressed in in Blood and
nasal swap samples from about a thousand
patients uh a cross-sectional
multi-institute study um pre-omicron
where case numbers weren't as high and
we validated these findings in
prospective studies so the study really
focused on the lungs but we've extended
this out to cardiac placenta and brain
studies
um in in this workflow
so this is now going through those um
tissue samples in the lungs so we're
able to identify the majority cell types
within the lung tissues by uh defining
regions of Interest so we're able to
identify the hyaline membranes the type
2 pneumocytes the bronchial epithelial
cells so you can see you can almost the
the most similar
um sort of way of characterizing these
is is sort of laser capture micro uh
micro dissection so you can almost
Define these regions of Interest so you
can see in this bronchial epithelial
layer you can almost Shadow over that
and you can Liberate the transcript of
the protein data straight off that using
those tiny mirrors and and the UV light
so we were able to define the majority
cell types for these regions of Interest
um this is not just toggling through
looking the virus in the red
um and these are you know representative
regions of interest within that tissue
and this is on the whole transcriptome
data when we're looking at cell typing
so this is a cell a convolution map
where we can see the covet going across
in the red and the normal in the blue
and the different cell types within
those regions of interest and we were we
were really interested in the subsets of
immune cells and we did an immune cell
Decon over these so now this is getting
a further sort of uh layer of data on
the on the immune cell subtypes and you
can see the cell types on the right
there again the red going across is the
covet samples and the blue um is the
non-covet or the normal tissue samples
and when we go on to the PCA so the
dimension reduction analysis this is a
helicopter overview of your transcript
data if you focused on the figure on the
right you can see the kobit 19 samples
in the blue the H1N1 samples in the red
and the normal healthy control samples
in the yellow so you've got these two
sort of populations present in this
cohort again this is transcript data
Global overview and then focus on the
figure on the right we now overlay that
with the chords where we where each
color represents an individual patient
so again transcript data where each
color represents a patient you've still
got these two populations which weren't
really clear to us what this was so then
we overlaid the the majority cell type
pathology assessment over the
transcriptome data and what we could see
was that the PCA on the PCA plot the
cell types separated out the transcript
level data so you could see the bronchi
epithelial cells at the bottom right the
hyaline membrane in the yellow
um the the types of pneumocytes in the
light blue and so on so it really shows
you the power of integrating
um spatial RNA data with that majority
cell type assessment or the pathology
assessment essentially and how those two
data sets really come together
um we then went on to look at
differentially expressed genes between
covid-19 versus control and H1N1 and one
of the top differentially expressed
genes that were highly upregulated in
covid-19 with um these type 1 interferon
response genes specifically IFI 27 came
up in multiple data sets and in
orthogonal data sets for us in tissue
and luckily on the call we had Kirsty
shorts short to the leading virologist
in the country and
um she almost shrieked on the zoom call
which is incredible because it's been
known that IFI 27 was elevated in the
blood of covid-19 patients but they
hadn't tied that to the tissue finding
so this was one of the earlier studies
showing uh where the signal was coming
from in the tissue and we we then went
on to look at the viral load again you
can type 1 interferon response comes up
this is looking at high virus versus low
virus by RNA scope and then low viral
load as well
and and we've done some Gene enrichment
analysis and you can see the pathways
that are activated here so interferon
gamma a blood coagulation hypoxia uh
interferon Alpha
um again and we've got the waterfall
plots here to map back to this and what
was really unique from our study was
that when we compared out
um the differentiate expressed genes
that were found in our study versus
those that were publicly available at
the time there appeared to be a very
unique signature for covid-19 which
included IFI 27 in there and we've since
published the study in the European
respiratory Journal which came out late
last year and it really showed the you
know the power of of spatial to really
inform on on discovery type approaches
for biomarkers potentially
um so all now sort of transition into
you know we've done that whole fly
tissue um assessment and we're moving
towards that single cell subcellular
assessment and we were able to
um collaborate with Nano string on a on
the new um Cosmic subcellular technology
which really enables you to do a deep
dive on the individual cell types and
subcellular assessments so this is the
cosmics uh platform where we looked at
about a thousand transcripts per cell
again on a on an on a new uh GMA where
we had 20 patient samples again lungs
um in duplicate both biological and
Technical technical uh replicas and we
had control lung tissue as well as the
comparator and the fields of view on the
cosmics platform are what are what are
demarcated in these yellow sort of
compartments and each in within each
compartment you can capture about 50 000
individual cells at a thousand
transcripts per cell level and this is
just looking at a sort of overview of
that and you can see the broad
structures within this so the RNA is on
the right the proteins on the left and
we're able to do a deep dive where every
dot here represents a transcript in
these samples
and what we wanted to do was to compare
across these so our first step was to
look at the RNA scope to localize where
the virus was in the cell types where
the virus was infecting and you can see
very clearly that you've got a sort of a
heterogeneous uh sort of expression
level of RNA scope which is expected
across the individual patient sample
excuse me and what you can see is that
the RNA scope highlights the Sask of 2
in the red and you've got your composite
immunofluorescence image in the middle
which is based on pan side occurs in
cd45 and CD3 and then on the right
that's transcript level data that you're
looking at the single uh molecule uh
transcript level data that you're
looking at if we zoom in on this you can
see the RNA scope um is is really
tagging this almost this boundary on on
on on the bottom here and what we can do
is we can identify the different cell
types within there but we can now if you
focus on the figure on the on the right
this is looking at IFI 27 in the red
cxcl10 in the yellow and cd31 in the
purple but this is single transcript
level information so every dot there
represents a single transcript
when we then look at the clustering and
the data normalization this is now
plotting every cell position on the
tissue microarray we're then able to QC
and filter the data and we can see the
covet samples in the blue the the
control in the red and and good
separation of the two and when we
normalize the data we can see the two
sort of uh populations separate out
really well here
um in in our data set and when we go on
to the unsupervised clustering and the
data normalization from that um to infer
cell type information we can see um this
is now plotting the different cell types
within that population within the covet
and the control sample and what was
really notable in the study was that we
could see that this box here in the red
is is highlights the covid samples and
the controls are are the two
um bars on the right so that we can see
good clustering of the of the covet from
the normal
um and and the different cell
populations within that and we're
actually at the moment trying to to do a
deep dive on the different cell types
within that and I'll just touch on some
of the initial analysis on this
subcellular assessment
um study where we're looking at the
spatial map
um here on the on the top left and the
different cell types which are some of
which are labeled here
when we look at the macrophage component
of these we can now compare between
covid
um positive samples versus control
samples and we can see in the macrophage
component IFI 27 is highly upregulated
or differentially expressed in in the in
this in this in this study um between
the uh covet versus the control lung
tissue but we can also see that in the
High virus infected samples by RNA scope
versus the covet positive samples where
we're not picking up virus but we can
see again IFI 27 is one of those top
differentially expressed genes and it
appears to be
localizing to this macrophage
compartment so we're doing a lot more
work in this space which is really
exciting but it's really showing you you
know you do the gene Discovery work with
or the signature work with the DSP
geomix up front and then you can do a
real deep dive on the on the
on the individual thousands of cellular
using the cosmics platform so i527 was
one of those key genes that we wanted to
investigate in the blood and the nasal
samples of of
um covid-19 patients and what we did in
a in a retrospective and a prospective
study across the globe almost so in
Brazil Chile the U.S Singapore Australia
and Denmark we looked at about a 800
patients and about 108 controls
pre-omicron at IFI 27 levels in the
blood and the nasal swaps within the
first few days of symptom monsters and
we could show that IFI 27 alone was a
predictive for disease severity when
measured within the first few days of
symptom onset and this was RFI 27
specifically in the blood and uh we had
a you could see in a stepwise manner
that severe patients patients that
developed severe covid-19 symptoms
within the when you measured I5 27 in
the blood and not the nasal swords
within the first few days it predicted
for disease severity so those that went
on to to to to ICU and those that didn't
and this is just looking an Australian
cohort where we can show that IFI 27
outperforms other clinical assessments
such as lymphopenia CRP age
comorbidities and symptom score
I'll quickly touch on some of the really
exciting work in the cardiac space so
this is looking at covid-19 cardiac
tissue versus control and what was
really notable in this study we looked
at 10 patients uh um 10 patients uh from
from
um covid-19 positive uh patients H1N1
and control uh cardiac tissue and we we
this is just looking at the
differentially expressed uh genes and we
when we look at the genes that are
upregulated in covid versus H1N1 so this
is a a a map showing um what are the
what are the genes that enrichment uh
scores
um four covet versus uh H1N1 we can see
a DNA damage signature is really high in
the covid-19 population and it is down
regulated in H1N1 but when we look at
H1N1 we can see that the inflammatory
sort of isgs all your interferons are
upregulated in influenza but they are
down regulated in in the cardiac tissue
of covert 19. so the study really shows
the differences in in cardiac tissue
um from saskov II infection and H1N1 and
we've got a preprint out on this work
currently and I'll quickly touch on the
placental covid-19 study where we looked
at about 10 covid-19 third trimester
positive covid-19 positive placentas
versus gestational age match controls
and what was really interesting in the
study was we could identify a
pre-eclampsia signature which was
specific to the covid-19 patients
um and again it really shows that extra
pulmonary effect of covid-19 and and why
so much work needs to be done looking at
the long-term effects of covid-19 and
this is a really you know an early study
but it really shows you the power of
spatial to really understand what's
going on in these tissues where you can
often not find virus so we couldn't find
virus by RNA scope in the placenta or
the myocardial tissue it is it was very
much located to the lungs of these
patients but there are these extra
pulmonary effects
um with that I'd like to thank all the
collaborators on this study um namely
Fernando gamares Kirsty short Gabriel
Bell Melissa Davies and her team a
wonderful team at the Wilson Eliza Hall
John Fraser and his lab and and we've
got a number of papers out in the space
and and a few more to come
um and the patients have contributed the
valuable samples to the study and the
funding agencies thank you I welcome any
questions
all right everyone thanks for listening
to that presentation so we have arutha
here for the live q a portion of the
webinar so please go ahead and put your
questions into the question window so we
can get started with some q a
um there is one question for you rusa
did you check if your virus detection
spots also have ace2 expressors and if
not what is the entry port on the
cellular surface
thanks Elizabeth
um that's a great question we so with
the RNA scope we found it challenging in
that initially we ran the classical 2
and when we could see a very puncted
sort of pattern in it we couldn't
resolve that further we are currently
looking at H2 expression as well so it's
a good sort of thing that we're dealing
at at the lab but I don't have a
response at this stage um the only thing
we looked for by RNA scope by RN scope
was the virus itself
excellent thank you so much
so let me see if we have any additional
questions
um so I have a question for you Orissa
um so now that um you know uh Nana
string has presented at aacr the spatial
proteogenomic workflow for looking at
RNA and protein simultaneously are you
thinking about doing that for any
upcoming experiments
yeah absolutely so that was a I think a
really important uh finding because
typically we would go through a block to
do RNA and protein but being able to do
that sort of multi-ohomic assessment of
a single tissue section is really
powerful so we're looking to adopt that
workflow um pretty quickly
um so we were really excited it was the
first time we'd seen that um the poster
being presented at asdr so I think that
sort of you know directionally that's
what everyone wants because as you move
through through a block
um you are moving through cells and and
potentially not even the same plane so
being able to get that simultaneous
protein and RNA readout is important of
the same section so it's great that
that's been developed and that we can
apply that workflow and it looked like
it was a pretty standard workflow that
we could adopt so we're really Keen to
now use that
excellent thank you so much
let me see if we have any other
questions that have come in
so another question
um you know what what's next for you
guys in terms of the covid-19 studies
yeah so we we're doing a deep dive on
the cosmics at the moment so that's been
really insightful
um there's a the data is quite you know
it's not a heavy um at this day so we
did the you know the signature work with
the geomix up front and now we're sort
of doing a deep dive on the Single Cell
sub cellular workflow using the cosmic
technology and from initial you know I
showed a bit about it today
um the initial findings are really
promising
um around around the you know the study
the localization the cell phone
interactions but I think there's an
additional layer of when you start to
look at transcripts transcripts in space
and you know the the transcript
interactions and and so on so we're
excited by the cosmics but I think it's
a very data heavy
um approach but but it's great right
it's got a lot of um sort of Discovery
uh tools there that we can develop so
we're we're doing a deep dive on the
cosmics at the moment then the cosmic
startup
excellent thank you so much
um another question one of the theories
of long coveted is that some SARS
related lesions and per there are some
SARS related lesions and peripheral
tissues
um which actually point on extra lung
virus I don't know if that's a question
or just a statement for you to comment
on
sorry Elizabeth could you repeat that I
didn't get the full question
um it says one of the theories of long
covet is that there are some SARS
related lesions and peripheral tissues
which actually points to having extra
virus in the lungs
right
um so we've we've looked at we've looked
at a sort of multi-organ study um in
matched patients too we looked at the
lungs cardiac brain placenta uh tissue
and we could only localize virus to buy
RNA scope to the to the lungs we did see
extra pulmonary effects
um multi-inflammatory
um we've got a early pre-print on the
cardiac study where we've identified DNA
damage in in covid-19 cardiac tissues
which is very different to H1N1 which
elicits an inflammatory response whereas
in in covid it's a DNA damage response
that we're seeing
um we we aren't able to find virus in in
the placenta nor the brain nor the nor
the cardiac tissue so
um I think the peripheral sort of extra
pulmonary organ studies are going to be
critical to understand the impact of
long covet um I'd love to share some of
the brain data but it's brand new and
then hopefully we'll be able to get that
out soon um it's it's you know there are
changes we're seeing in the in in in
covid-19 brain tissue that's also
um yeah I think you know there's so much
unknown but using these Discovery tools
and you know good cohorts will be able
to identify hopefully um you know new
insights into the disease biology and
hopefully it's a long-term impact of
covert
great and a question I actually have you
mentioned that you're going to be
looking at some of the tissues of
cosmics
um do you envision in the future sort of
using geomix to do
um sort of at the whole transcriptome
level
um you know a discovery type experiment
and then for the tissue samples that are
of most of Interest then diving deeper
into say a cereal section with cosmics
to look at the Single Cell level yeah I
think you hit the nail in the head there
um Elizabeth
um you know the the geometric is tied
throughput you know we can run multiple
samples a day on that um so you know if
you're trying to run let's say 50
samples you could do that within you
know a couple of days within with the
geomix and then based on your findings
you could then narrow that down to a
subset of samples that you want to do a
deep dive one and get the sort of single
cell interaction work and then do the
cosmics all night so I think the geomix
up front for the discovery would be key
and then and cosmics where you really
narrow it down I I guess you could do it
the other you know you could go cosmics
up front but you probably wouldn't have
that throughput that's needed um and and
the you know the end numbers so I I
highly recommend geomix up front at
least to identify you know signatures of
importance for your disease model and
then to to then go into the cosmics
workflow I plant another question for
any of the lung samples that you looked
at did any of those um
decedents have any comorbidities
associated with them with their
treatment or with their condition
yeah no there was so so obviously these
are all rapid autopsy samples so they
are they are end stage
um
which you know it's hard to get lung
tissue from earlier cases so we there
are multiple comorbidities even in the
in the lung and the cardiac studies
there are sort of
analyzes we're looking at in that in
that space um so there are definitely a
few uh confounding factors there
excellent
all right well um this is your last
chance to get in some questions
um and arusa is very kindly dialing in
for us all the way from Australia so um
take advantage of the time that you have
with him um he's actually presented
um for
um The Labyrinth chronovirus event on an
earlier
um virtual event that we had last year
and he's also done a lot of work with
the geomix looking at immune
infiltration and cancer so
um it's really well versed in that space
of studying the immune microenvironment
both in cancer and infectious disease so
if you have any additional questions
now's your chance to get them out
yeah absolutely it's been such a
powerful tool in the i o space um
obviously you know your traditional
um checkpoint inhibit therapies don't
have good predictive biomarkers at the
moment so we've used we've done a deep
dive on the team and micro environment
um and there's some real novel insights
that we're gaining so it's definitely a
tool that you can use pen disease model
um especially if you're interested in
discovery type work
[Music]
um thanks everyone for joining and thank
you again arutha for your time
thank you